the gyro can experience why wouldn't we
assume that the reason why we're so
conflicted and weird is because that's
the proper mechanism that needs to be in
place for people to move forward in the
direction that we're moving forward to
be the be constantly chasing technology
without any real clear sort of a
rational approach to using our resources
and looking at the problems that we have
because we're like a bunch of little
kids that have liked shit all over their
house but instead we're outside working
on the garden you know we're planting
trees we're not cleaning up the shit
that we piled up in the middle of the
living room and it keeps piling up every
day to the point where we can't even
live in our house anymore
we're concentrating on some shit that's
not even ours do you think you could
ever live you probably couldn't but
maybe in your maybe say like if you
didn't have kids in the faming families
do you think you could ever live in like
one of those Airstream trailers but
myself fuck yeah because I was recently
I recently went to you know Joshua Tree
in one of those and I was thinking like
really this is all I really need and I
could take my whole fucking house
anywhere I want in the new ones I have
like nice wood floors and I have some of
them expand out you know there's there's
been you know a lot of people that are
moving towards minimalist house is
really small houses but there's a bunch
of online that show like how certain
people live it's kind of interesting you
know like one guy figured out a way to
have like this little tiny cooking area
and he pulls the bed out and the bed
comes out of the wall he lives by
himself and he has like some storage up
in top like toilet paper and things
along those lines
but it's a tiny tiny little house in a
little kitchen dinette area and you know
the idea is that like really why do we
have to have this giant fucking
footprint of a house that we live in
because you're getting paid bitch if I
want to live in a fucking cell I'll live
in a fucking sound like a monkey I'm
gonna live with a fold-up bed like I'm
James Bond like some fucking boy Rican
that gets a check on the fifth go fuck
your mother if you get paid you live in
a fucking house I'm gonna live in a
micro fucking house with a little
kitchen so cook like I got a black guy
bagging me in the fuckin ass I don't
leave that you spread out even me I'm no
millionaire I got a big fucking kitchen
a micro house what are you fucking
people talking about I just snapped out
of this dog you can't take me into those
deep waters like you read the fucking
kills a brother right now a fucking
house with a bed upside down fuck that
shit to say better you fuck you you get
paid you fucking live like a normal
purse
go to Trump and say hey wig move into a
fucking thing to say but if you don't if
you don't have a Russian bitch slapping
in the fucking fire the fuck these
people micro houses in the fucking
desert you play it out to the world ends
like a doctor like a doctor you live
your fucking life you're right
doomsday I'm gonna put a can of tomato
soup under my stairs don't wait for the
Martians to come when it's over it's
over you go out when they were your dick
on you take your fucking chances like a
man I'm gonna live like a fuckin old
twenty dollars to a bookmaker downstairs
in my house get the fuck out of my face
Brian's down Joey's not and you have a
real clear line feel like you're in one
when you're in there it's so somebody
farts and you're in for fucking speed
FISA and you're like I paid $10,000 so I
can smell your asshole get the fuck out
of here because everything's great in a
small space till somebody blows the
fucking fart you will walk into a
bathroom after somebody else shit it
fuckin bothers you even pay your mother
you look at them like you dirty fucking
bitch light a candle something you know
I don't wanna sell you don't want to
live nothing small fuck that shit I'm
never home though you know like I work
so much I'm never hired you're always
fuckin I'm on the sleep
[Applause]
[Music]